salut romain qu'est-ce que tu es en
train de perdre on est peut être sont
loin et comme on est pressé je me suis
dis que tu as mangé des asperges non
mais comment tu sais tu étais médium a
besoin
[Musique]
pour te mange une banane notre pepy qui
sont le pipi quand on mange un concombre
notre pipi sur le pipi alors pourquoi
quand on mange une asperge notre pipi
ils sont l'aspergent là ça ça c'est là
qu'est tout commence par un repas normal
avant le dessert il est là en sauce
avant le plat quelques asperges tenté
dans la vinaigrette
rien ne laisse présager le drame qui se
noue en silence quelques minutes après
avoir quitté la table pourtant frédéric
le groupe ares se rend aux commodités
s'il fait face à l'horreur
plus absolu
son pipe
sur l'aspect comment tout a basculé en
un instant pour comprendre il faut
remonter aux origines de la tragédie
quand on mange une asperge comme quand
on mange n'importe quel aliment elle se
retrouve très vite dans l'estomac où
elle est dégradée par des sucs digestifs
des acides des enzymes etc
les différents composés issus de cette
dégradation sont ensuite absorbé par les
parois du tube digestif et se retrouve
dans la circulation sanguine pour
nourrir les organes et le reste finit
dans les urines après avoir été filtrés
par les rangs dans le cas qui nous
intéresse l'aspergent elle contient de
l'acide asparagus zik qui est dégradée
en composés qui contiennent du soufre
comme le méthane et yonne et le sulfure
de diméthyle et quand on fait des
dosages après avoir mangé des asperges
on se rend compte qu'on retrouve ces
composés très rapidement dans les urines
à des taux mille fois supérieur à de
l'uriné classique et ces substances en
plus d'être éliminée très rapidement
dans les urines
on parle d'une quinzaine de minutes
elles ont la particularité d'être très
odorante le méthane et hiolle par
exemple il fait partie d'une famille de
composés organiques qu'on retrouve dans
l'épais dans le liquide qui est sécrétée
par les putois et qui sont aussi
utilisés pour fabriquer les boules
puantes et aussi la substance qu'on
ajoute dans le gaz que vous utilisez
chez vous pour lui donner une odeur
particulière qui le rend plus faciles à
repérer en cas de suite qu'à la base le
gaz ça n'a pas d'odeur
on parle du gaz domestique celui pour
faire chauffer l'eau on est d'accord
alors je sais y en a parmi vous qui ne
se sont jamais posé cette question tout
simplement parce que vous n'avez jamais
remarqué que votre pipi sens fort après
avoir mangé une asperge on peut formuler
trois hypothèses à ce sujet soit vous
mangez jamais d'aspect rj et vous ne
renouvelez jamais le pipit secondes soit
votre pipi ne sont pas l'aspergent quand
vous en mangez soit votre pipi sans
l'aspergent mais vous ne vous en rendez
pas compte il n'y a pas grand chose à
tirer de la première hypothèse donc on
va se concentrer sur les deux autres et
il se trouve qui a plusieurs chercheurs
qui se sont déjà penchés sur la question
ah c'est un beau métier chercheurs le
résultat ces différentes études parce
qu'il y en a eu plusieurs
c'est que les deux dernières hypothèses
sont valables certaines personnes
produisent une urine qui ne sent pas
l'aspergent après en avoir mangé on sait
pas pourquoi
et d'autres personnes ne détecte pas
l'odeur des asperges dans les urines
alors qu'elles contiennent pourtant les
fameuses substances odorantes dont on a
parlé et là pour le coup ce serait dû à
une variation génétique de certains
capteurs de
voilà maintenant vous savez voilà
détester c'est fini pour aujourd'hui si
vous avez d'autres questions de ce genre
envoyez les moi à l'adresse question dtc
@ gmail point com
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout porté julien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]